Lakers right in the passing lane then
it's going to be a launch by Knox
nothing but air he'll get serenaded look
at this pass the gate see look out look
out those who dangers yeah Portis that
caldwell-pope you saw the headband fly
there and he was hit bid and about to
throw it down he got a no-bail look at
Rajan right in his face all he got was
head of Kentavious caldwell-pope kcp
saying wow where where is everybody this
is that that is dangerous because one he
jumps off of one foot very fortunate to
be able to get himself in a position to
land the way he landed they're gonna
review this obviously because anytime
this contact with the head nospace EP is
up and the crowd gives me a nice hand be
able to just get up look at this off of
one getting ready to swat it and move
look oh that's good that will be out
later oh yeah about it boy though the
roundhouse way the bobby portis went
after him - yeah yeah that's that is
definitely going to catch the Iowa
officials wouldn't got surprised my here
I know what to do yeah I know what
you're gonna say with because of the way
yeah the blow Ericka Lewis mark I
Mansel are pixels the crowd just saw the
replay on the board and you could bet
what their reaction is bobby portis
getting a look at it too and the good
news is that the kc p yes they kicked
him out of a bedroom - yeah that didn't
surprise me at all though just it was
the way that he yeah kind of wild on yes
yes that's the whole thing the way he
delivered the contact
he catches kcp across the head I mean
all of it I mean right at the temple to
start and just go all the way up man kcp
is very fortunate he was able to get his
feet back under him the way he did
support us down the tunnel into the
locker room done for the night again
they're already short-handed with Morris
and a Dennis Smith not available you
know I harp on that jumping off of one
foot a lot because I had a couple of
experiences like that as a player jumped
off of one and
got hit at the top didn't get my feet
back under me tried to catch myself and
land it on my wrist out for six months
would have broken the VIC Euler so it's
just a very dangerous play as kcp is
going back to the locker room because it
was a flagrant foul I believe I think he
is able to come back into the game at
some other point
well they'll check that they'll go
through the protocol now with kcp for
sure not protecting a blow to the head
like that he will be checked on so Danny
Green is shooting the free throw